because of currency devaluing people see
their wages flatlining and asset price
is going through the roof this kind of
disguises a wage
collapse as a house price bubble
increased inequality is pushing wages
down but a devaluation of the currency
is pushing wages up which mean the two
things balance out and that means that
instead of seeing wages falling what you
see is Wages kind of flatlining while
the prices of everything else go through
the roof such as house prices stock
prices food prices Energy prices natural
resource
prices and this really changes the way
that ordinary people perceive what is
happening so if you didn't have that
devaluation of currency people would be
able to see damn my wage is falling why
is my wage falling and we might be able
to have a discussion about well this is
happening because of rising inequality